une re découverte maintenant s'en lasse
pas voici les toutes dernières images du
titanic le bateau qui a fait naufrage il
ya près d'un siècle est au coeur vous le
savez d'une nouvelle expédition
scientifique à 4000 mètres de profondeur
les premiers documents viennent d'être
rendues publiques commentaires gilles
marie n'est par 4000 mètres de fond au
large de terre-neuve
voici la proue du titanic elle vient de
surgir dans le faisceau des projecteurs
d'un sous-marin robot l'engin est équipé
de caméras ultra sophistiqué jamais on
avait pu observer l'épave avec autant de
précision et surprise pour les
spécialistes
elle n'est pas aussi rouillé qu'il le
pensait et c'est pourtant écoulé 81 18
ans depuis le départ triomphale de la
côte anglaise à destination de new york
réputé insubmersible le plus grand
transatlantique au monde allait pourtant
heurté un iceberg
c'était le 14 avril 1912
plus de 1500 morts la plus grande
catastrophe maritime en temps de paix
l'épave du titanic est un monument aux
disparus il est impossible bien sûr de
la ramener à terre mais grâce à ces
images qui seront traités en trois
dimensions nous pourrons tous un jour
visiter un titanic virtuel réplique
minutieuse de l'épave